the technology of the Telegraph changed
the world in such fundamental ways the
Telegraph really was the foundation of
telecommunications this collection
contains not just books but other
materials that illustrate the impacts of
that technology on the world we have
telegrams that were sent during the
Civil War even though they were
electrified and sent over however many
hundreds or thousands of miles they
began and ended as paper documents and a
lot of that is held in mi t--'s
collection serve only these telegrams
have messages that simply say
grandmother died uncle Henry is gone
telegrams came to be associated with bad
news Western Union wanted to combat that
they started having celebratory standard
telegrams that you could purchase for
cheap and since somebody may be a happy
birthday message baby Grahams wedding
announcements one of the telegrams is
from a woman and the message of course
that had to be kept under 10 words
because it got expensive to send more
than that many the message is
essentially destitute homeless please
wire money the lines didn't just appear
overnight they had to be put in and
oftentimes over tough terrain it was
very dangerous work their wiring the
wilderness the Atlantic cable was seen
as one of the wonders of the 19th
century when it was completed in 1858
and really could be seen as one of the
first steps toward globalization the
cable was seen as a harbinger of world
peace because it would enable more
immediate communication it but somehow
dispelled disagreement Goethe purcha
it's this rubber material that came from
a tree in Malaysia they coated every
submarine cable with it in the process
using many millions worth of gutta trees
it got used so much that the trees
almost went extinct
Victorians realized they had to do
something they started actually
replanting trees and became much more
conscious of the damage they done in the
process of wiring the globe with
submarine cables this material may be
most valuable for the sociologist and
the humanists at MIT who are looking at
the way communication changed personal
messages being sent from one home to
another messages that tell very quiet
stories but tell them in a very
immediate and poignant way